smith rowe no where which mean where
where is he going to play to play uh
number 10 position play out white he
said who well you got there
you've got folding grealish mahrez
playing front and realish
he play in front of a green scroll's a
better player than greelish this season
smith throws been better
the aston villa greenish already
[Music]
where's the red carpet for the champions
and
big steve in the building oh yeah how
are you doing man all right mate yes
yeah good night
all right it's gonna be tasty already i
know because we're always arguing
yeah let's go ready
manchester city will never be as big a
club as arsenal
three
two one
go on
never
are you joking
never not right in our history
oh the history of arsenal goes way back
to this way way better channel no but to
be a big club to be you you said we'll
never all right okay so be a really
really big club you've got uh that's
part of it but what does that actually
mean
hold on that's part of being a big club
is the history behind it you don't just
turn up you know this week and become
that big club we just turned up and more
more premier league trophies than you
yeah we all know why
you would you'd have it straight away
wouldn't you we all know i wouldn't say
i wouldn't have it i wouldn't have you
know but we're talking about so the way
i'm going to say is this yeah
i'd rather win the trophies
yeah than win nothing and be called a
big club
what is a big club so you walk down the
street people say steve champions again
a goal yes mate they go rubber big club
again and you go yeah man no you walk
down the street and they say oh that's a
sea fan oh i've actually found one
that's just jealousy though no that's
fast jealous that's facts whereas i walk
down the street and many others walk
down the street because there's arsenal
fans throughout the world it's a it's a
huge catchphrase with the history of
this club with the fan base of this club
we will always be bigger we're bigger
than you now you're not bigger than us
now you're living in france no you win
more than us you're living in france you
know i win more than australia 20 years
ago you was a club who i looked up to
and i thought you know what arsenal are
everything we wanted to still look up to
why you're a banter club now you should
still look up all you're famous for now
is hot dogs
youtube views and banter what's your
favorite for monet oil and trophies
exactly i'll take that listen i'll tell
you what it is right this bigger club
myth manchester city fans we don't care
about that you know why we don't care
about it because what is it actually
thing people saying stadiums is one your
don't talk to me about four things
you're talking about your lady mate full
mate no somebody has to stay themselves
out every week try and get a season to
get out of here try and get scenes to
get out please
on here and say your stadium is full
because people will come at you with all
the people listen when
when do you see when also in the
champions league we never see an empty
seat you know what you know what you
have a meltdown if you're team seventh
in the premier league imagine if he was
fifteen from division two no we're not
you wouldn't exist mate you'd be
supporting ballroom we're not used to it
you support you'll be able to use that
sometimes dogs thinking i never used it
you've got tottenham you just got
invited to the party man pipe down
you're
we've built what we've got did you know
right what have you built did you know
you've used
even that stadium you you're boring
that's that's loose change to our man in
it the stadium he wants to stadium the
commonwealth that was for those of us
that's a great deal that's what the
effects weren't even yours swap main
road for a brand new stadium you go two
million a year flat rent it's business
you're already paying for it you're a
business we paid for us yeah and you've
cost you 15 years in old trophies yeah
but you know what we've done it we paid
for it we're moving in that direction
we've done that now what direction
don't worry we'll be back bro yummy this
is saying that for 15 years what
happened to you as i said did you not
come back
did you not come back
so why can't we come back big club like
awesome worldwide brent champions of
england again aren't we congratulations
you've got a very good team we have
we've just done you five now you did
money well spin
no arsenal players would get into
manchester city's team
three
two one
[Music]
well first of all i was thinking maybe
sakura but left back but the concello's
playing at left back left back yeah left
back that's probably the only way but we
do need someone that can carry the water
bottles
on the pitch so you know i i think
that's what you're
you're you're a
um
i think aaron ramsdale
could get in even though i think
edison's a quality keeper i think aaron
ramsdale
could have a shout um and he's hated him
two months he made a few mistakes this
season isn't anything it's shaky nice
big part of what we do you know a bit
shaky ramsdale's playing one long ball
you've been a bit shaky would you say
edison a little bit shaky this season
top of the league in it i've been a bit
shaky
come on not enough to put
he's lit through his you know he's
been a bit flappy this
ramstell
um
that's it and that is
yeah put it back
listen man i'll back my team 100
you're struggling nowhere now i've
struggled
ramsdale
in the 10. you got to get in the 10.
smith rowe no where do you mean where
where is he going to play he complained
that he could play uh number 10 position
play out white he said who well you got
there
well we
have we got folding grealish mahrez
gundam where are you playing from
the aston villa greenish are rated no
but you did because this season there's
a difference this season
even your own manager i said he ain't
turned up
you know you've got a hundred million
pound headache you bought a player
that's not performing listen he's still
better smith rowe smith rowe has been
performing way better than him this
season
he's speaking you don't get nothing
i was just talking about that he'd be
playing with better ones
turn up when you played us
we rolled you five nil why won't you but
that wasn't throws forward
without a ten men
that was not smith rowe's four but emil
smith rowe has been one of the best i'm
not scraping about one of the best young
players in but you don't get football
yes
if greenish gets in he gets it do you
know what though we're greelish at
manchester city
from the manchester city supporters the
ones that count not the media and
everyone else that talks there's no
pressure on chuck greelish we don't put
pressure on our players to perform
we trust pep guardiola the whole of
england
was screaming two months ago three
months ago for him to be playing for
england in the euros begging southgate
to play him me included so right blocks
doing all right but he's not a wide left
player however at this moment in time
he's not playing as well as smith rowe
smith rowe's best positions are number
10 and he's been playing out on the left
and i think um
um rams though okay no no rams they were
kidding who plays um
yeah no ramsey that's gonna say right
back but i forgot walker in that yeah
yeah yeah listen you've got an
unbelievable team man money's well spent
so you've got to be
honest look at your team
look at our team and think i'll be dead
on this now none of them are getting in
there no no none of them that's why i
say i disagree because when you say none
of them
i disagree ain't buying wrong
disagreement
i disagree i don't know all it takes is
for edison to have one bad season and
the chip that might be done
you know what i mean what did you spend
for ramsdale 24 million well we only
spent 35 for edison
we only spent 35. that's what i mean and
liverpool's past 75
the invincibles were a better side than
pepsman city side are now
three two one
oh whoa
let's see what i'm affair man
am i fair man
we're a good side but the invincible i
don't know it was just i thought if you
would have said the centurion team
that got the most points
i would have
centurions no centralians man ghosts and
trying to put that back there no you
never lost
ghost and choreography you're going to
let these people everyone even let me
familiar you'll let me expendables
you're gonna let me speak on this one
yeah
right let me just get this into your
head yeah invincibles you won the league
didn't lose a game great
you play football to win yeah when you
win you get three points yeah we won the
league centurions the highest ever
points total in english football history
let me tell you this if manchester city
draw 38 games next season
we are invincible and relegated
there you go so what would you rather be
it's true 38 points you're invincible
you're relegated you're relegated you
get the highest ever points total in
english football history that is a
better achievement than that little gold
trophy they got over kinder egg and gave
you to make you feel like
that was pathetic me i i thought it was
some big trout he lifted this thing i
thought wow my daughter's got their
hands
got it no but this isn't right
that season
better balance sheet more youtube
followers invincibles little gold trophy
you can keep all that desperate keep it
moving
that's season you might as well have
that there look at arsene wenger lifting
that there we're invincible nice one
mate every season you are desperate
right nobody cares about that there are
people like oh
um
you can um i think so you can go to the
whole league and beat them never come in
and then never crumble never come from a
city fall apart we don't care about them
things they're not yeah you don't care
about it because you ain't got it that's
all you've got no you don't care about
it you ain't got it you cannot meet an
arsenal fan that doesn't mention that
this is a great achievement the
centurion's dog it's the highest ever
points
no team will ever win every domestic
trophy in the country alex ferguson said
that and we won it alex ferguson also
laughed at arsene wenger when he
suggested that that arsenal team could
go a season unbeaten yeah the season
before i think they'd only lost one game
one game actually wouldn't even break it
down one game lost in two seasons you
can't tell me that you wouldn't want to
shut me up from mentioning that will you
be saying you can't tell me
what my life i'm not pregnant listen i
know you yeah i know you too well but
you wouldn't want to sharp guys like me
you haven't done that there's always
something else
got that in fact
and i go up i'm going to get my team to
play for 38 draws and win a troll that's
what i'm going to do imagine that well
you didn't even go invincibles in
division two and you've got your cheat
what was jamie pollock in midfield are
you mad you didn't even go a season
invincible in division two and you got a
cheek to talk to us about winning the
premier league invincible
i know you love that so i'm not gonna
dump in your fire with it you know
you know
probably don't even know who you are
yeah
fans treated arsene wenger poorly
three
two one
um
you know it tell the truth he was on the
front line it's a very it's a very
i'm gonna kind of um stay a bit on the
fence with this all right because a very
very difficult
one
to answer
because on the one hand
and arsene wenger has admitted this
himself
well on the one hand right you don't
want to see
a great manager this manager gave me so
much joy
right watching invincible seasons
seasoning season out this team
you know challenging for the league
you know champions league final you know
i mean
he gave me so much joy as a manager
but then
which is something he's admitted since
even himself he stayed on too long yeah
he should have left after a couple of
those i think after the second fa cup
win
against villa
i felt at that time that was a perfect
time to leave i don't think he then had
another opportunity after beating
chelsea in the the fa cup when we beat
you in semis chelsea in the final nobody
expected that
i felt that was the time and he stayed
and he stayed
and i think it was quite obvious to
everybody
that
you know he was in the decline he did
get a sourdough didn't it near the end
it started to get sour because
what you've got what people who on the
outside don't understand is you've got a
legendary manager
so you've got some people that just
can't bring themselves to
saying anything bad against them yeah
but then you've got
a legendary managers is horribly in
decline we can all see it
and there's some people who got very
frustrated with the situation
and
started you know being pretty vocal on
it
i i don't think people are on the
outside of the situation understand i
don't know i agree i agree with what
you're saying because from the outside
looking in we just seen your greatest
ever manager getting pelters but it was
because he stayed too long it took a
long time you've got a difference in
fans as well you've got the old school
who were there through the wenger years
who
remember him as that then you've got the
newer arsenal fans were like we want to
win trophies get rid of him get rid of
and get rid of him he stayed too long
the abuse he got was hard to watch i've
got to say that it was hard to watch
hard to report
the good thing with city is the one
thing that we do get right manchina we
caught him at the right time france a
few fans went mad well he won as the
premier league but they knew now it was
going that way get rid pellegrini came
in did a great job guardiola came up
they did it in the right way all great
things
come to an end you can't stay forever no
and it was almost like so it's always a
really touchy subject with arsenal fans
you know and it was a you know you you
as an [ __ ] fan you felt bad
turning against him in a way yeah
because you're like he's such a great
manager and a great guy honorable guy
but yo as a fan of the club
i'm seeing a steep decline
and we all know one of the main reasons
for that decline is we need to change
and we took too long to do it and it's
it's
yeah so
timing
timing
cool that turned uh sad didn't you
crying me
get me a tissue
manchester city
bought their trophies
three two one
come on no
no i'm not having it it's a couple of
minutes
come on you said you're a fair amount oh
you want to touch that pie it's a fiver
come on man
no one over two billion no
you know what billions spent more
players you bought i think you just got
you know what embrace it man no i'm not
oh listen just just
embrace it than me but once you see one
titles and that you know i mean i think
you just got us
you just got to say to yourself you know
you just say to yourself say that it is
what it is you bought it but you bought
that's the facts you've bought it
newcastle
newcastle are attempting to do what you
you did now then they'll probably follow
a lot of the blueprint of what you did
chelsea bought it chelsea when chelsea
were nobody even in london i agree with
you on that but what i'm going to say is
we've
we've not just thrown money at it
willy-nilly we haven't done that went
abroad
yeah but
came in right there was no ffp and he
just picked everybody i'm a city fan
since 89 yeah and you know me i've ever
seen 89 i've been on my way everywhere
and there's been times in division two
where i'd come home from like grimsby
now my mum would go what what what are
you doing why are you wasting your
weekend watching that
and i was like you know what one day i
remember my mate saying to me got once
he went i reckon we've got an fa cup in
us before we die do you and i went yeah
yeah yeah fake up and had to talk that
someone said to me before you die man
sitting with the fa cup
we've won two fa cups five premier
leagues five league cups i've been to
the champions league final i can't find
shakespeare enough and the blue side of
manchester that's that much
off the red side for all them years can
finally go out the house with a chest
out and say you know what yeah we did
get bought by a guy but what a guy but
if he'd have bought anybody else in the
world everybody else wants it people
look at our club now and they call us
but they're dying for it i've been on a
journey from division two barnsley all
the way up to the bernabeu i won't swap
my football journey for anybody's
treble 99 you can keep that i've had my
aguero moment six one at old trafford
you know what i mean division two
relegated crying on the pitch i've had
all that
but that's my memory my football memory
with this team so this team's ingrained
in manchester so people that say you've
got no history you've got to know this
you can throw money at it you can't
because man city is a club you just
don't get it when they sit here like me
with my fans my supporters you have to
understand we've been in the mud not
seventh in the premier league not eight
in the premier league in the mud when
they were putting adverts in the paper
saying please come to main road the
club's going to go out of business we
were turning up 30 000 in division two
buying pies
just so the team survived and this is us
we won a lot around sheikh mansour thank
god bless him he's giving me the best
times of my life my son's been to
wembley
13 times or something like that he's
bored of it now he don't even go anymore
and i'm like wow so listen man city is a
club anyone out there you can call them
all you want but
this journey i've been on me listen
unbelievable
sorry about that i had to just go in
there still strongly disagreed
[Laughter]
what we're doing on this question it's
actually a disgrace to didier drogba
comparing him to sierra reef for big
game players we need to be comparing him
to the likes of diego maradona the
aerial really doesn't get tirion reed
doesn't get it see everyone
doesn't get on this list for big game
players